bonjour à tous les 12 et 19 juin
prochains dans quelques jours pour vous
défendre pour nous défendre nous allons
faire confiance au candidat de la droite
républicaine et du centre dont ont
besoin de cette confiance pour qu'un
groupe important celui des républicains
du centre existe à l'assemblée nationale
un groupe indépendant libre responsable
qui sera critiqué ce qui doit l'être
approuvé ce qui peut l'être et rappelé
en toute hypothèse au gouvernement au
chef de l'état et l'engagement qu'ils
ont pris mais aussi les attentes les
colères des préoccupations des français
là pourquoi je pense que la confiance
que vous témoignerez à ses députés à ces
candidats députés sortants ou nouveaux
candidats une confiance qui sera bien
placé